estou sentindo um piloto é o teu
o lado pessoal de quem fala é dar que
sejam muito bem vindos já mais de um
vídeo e mostra jack white ribbon pessoal
é o seguinte eu agora uma atualização
praia na areia que te queimares
diminuídos
é isso fazer o jogo tentar segurar um
pouco a cidade e ver coisas novas que
não via em pleitos anteriores quem sabe
não sai mas o foco vai ser em queimar é
inimiga é aquela que não deixa comer o
meu sem pai mesmo o de melo não dá bom
vamos lá tentar então a coisa anda aí
que a segunda feira é contínuo
estamos na sua história o [ __ ] susto eu
quero queimar inimigos agora bárbaros
cubanos frasco bons carros da escola e
vamos falar antes de abrir o jogo já
tive investigar como fazer esta coisa de
queimar as suas queimar coisas e pelo
que eu saí pelo que já tive e tenho
basicamente tirar cinco fotografias há
cinco épocas depois tem que comprar
fotos no mercado negro depois com
esforços e vou conseguir é de afogados
ruína e pois com esse domínio phuket e
sim vou conseguir comer o meu sem pai a
vontade só pra mim tu todo pra mim tô e
bom e se nós vamos fazer então vamos
explicar então na nossa cama de cinha e
vamos tentar tirar fotos as cuecas todas
as meninas da escola tudo tudo quero é
que toda hora pra quem faz a nossa
primeira vítima e já está aqui ó
vamos tentar encontrar com e ken ash
olha que já olhou
não não conseguir ganhar por cinco
fotografias ou um ataque quando é que eu
vou inclusive quando parece que o senhor
x eu consegui tirar uma foto com a qual
entretanto esta esta estava em sucedida
o ex-volante não é tapete off meimei 11
a io a sair foi [ __ ] são não há mais
fotos e mais fotos mais uma aqui ó do
este é muito fácil muito fácil porque é
preciso mais duas ou não seu pai o seu
pai não pode vir aqui na foto jeff peek
nela que uma tsunami com o cabelo rapado
a não estão é que a pedra preta no dia
11 que vai tira tira falei só faltou uma
é fã não é repetir o foco dele é um ano
seguro pessoal do que aquilo que é
preciso mais uma coisa pessoal só mais
uma e já esta a atitude proactiva eu só
preciso mais uma pessoa mais uma
cuequinha só só mais um mapa não só
edição dos deuses choque
uma destas deve conseguir no entanto
luís ex volante não é repetir o fumo
semelhante chaco lula e agora que já
temos cinco ex nós vamos ter que entrar
aqui algures no celular o telemóvel
dispositivo android com os sistemas de
rede é o caso agora vamos ter que sair
do ers show porque é fighters agora
entrou olha só o demônio que o nosso
telemóvel lobato unido o que une de
drogas e agora tenho aqui fora não tem
cigarros perfumados claro program
perfume fundo no fundo tudo mesmo e como
podem ver uma caixa de fósforos custa
cinco épocas 5 é que eu já tenho a
impressão de comprar aqui caixa de
fósforos ao everton aprece eliene objeto
that e hugo chávez huíla pinheiro e
ainda escuro em português significa
qualquer objeto tenha comprado aparece
por trás da escola é eu fui agora o
google france inter somente poderá ser
eternamente ok vamos lá então por trás
da escola eu acho que fica mais ou menos
aqui né amiga mmo gótica das trevas se
sabe que a gente está a caixa de
fósforos espero que vocês se montava o
tak tak nossa caixa é o que nós vamos
fazer é levar a caixa lá pro meio do
pátio onde está nossa inimiga e hugo
chávez é quem é agora deixe que os
fósforos não é exatamente iguais não só
pessoal a nossa inimiga quem nós
queremos matar que está procurando não
sempre para fazer o amor para cancelar
também é ópera onde será possível daqui
eu podia de vista eu não sei detalhes em
mim elas com deus eu acho que ela estava
por vir que venha matar né agora vamos
ter que ir à procura dela eu aposto que
ela já sabia ela tem um plano
maquiavélico para fugir de mim e
supostamente ela tem o cabelo ruim
o curto rosa seu avatar e esta que noel
já percebeu já previu que essa que sua
luta é inimiga eu vou estar muito rápido
logo de cara da usina e deve ser alguns
titular fora né é que é que eu sei é
exatamente esta coisa aqui então
explicar esta coisa de gasolina e vamos
colocar aqui no obaoba qual já encheu
agora vamos cobrar até a nossa inimiga e
vamos muito sutilmente a tirar um golpe
pra cima dela e depois de tirar com
fósforo ela deve ficar alguns aqui agora
por favor disse que elas não saíram
daqui não seriam é que está na china e
mega ok mas antes de tirarmos ubaldo eu
só quero ter certeza que tem os fósforos
que podia fazer isso rápido antes que
ela vai embora não é eu tenho que o
esforço de 30 que o balde tivemos nossa
então o ritual e não estou em ritual no
canto só deus está tudo bem tudo
aconteceu o acidente desculpa amiga
agora time sports hochi só precisa tirar
não fuja
agora vamos torcer para que ela fosse um
pouquinho pra não ficar ali eu pedalo
delas todas nem por cair no estilo
pessoal aí a ela quer lavar é um
daqueles tomar menino e não mais
conseguir ela ficou nua como assim ela
tá aí ó ainda tá tudo sujo e calma calma
vamos esperar o momento certo muito
certo para tirar o foco principal que já
não é fruto um médico é a ela está
concentrado lei não vai mais funcionar
eu tirava a eu acho que não fui o tempo
vai vir com uma van que depois foi
garçom fogo morreu transportava tinha
morrido
eu vou te pegar fogo está viva
assim olha lá cid vamos tentar fazer
isso através do toque pessoal só tem o
juiz fósforo já tem jogo suína e nossa
inimiga está a chegar vai só ela o fundo
atenção calma pessoal agora agora nós
temos que ser ainda mais rápido e agora
é miguel bom foi um acidente e fica aí
vamos olhar as fotos muito rápido agora
ela vai por onde e porquê porque mesmo
quem anda rápido vai aproveitar agora
aproveita agora foi mais rápida
é muito difícil o cenário de fósforo é
difícil claro manda não consiga tirar
enquanto o estado de espírito vai vai
conseguimos pessoal conseguir matar a
nossa inimiga
o seu pai é tudo nosso porque ficou tudo
escuro olha só todos temos casa agora
queremos fazer com ela sem esconder o
corpo aqui onde fugir
anda vai agora mas por dentro da google
agora eu estava por dentro da água mas
não consigo rodas que não só espero que
vocês tenham gostado deste vinho eu
tenho medo dos nossos comentários deste
tipo são coisas que eu não sei fazer
tempo e não sai não foi nenhum é isso
que vocês querem que começa a mostrar as
atualizações tempos em que só uma
atualização eu mostro inglês quando como
affleck por britto fiquem bem a próxima